our disappointment and concern is
profound that is from visa try this one
we have repeatedly expressed our
concerns that is from this shoe cook
they spoke yeah FIFA stop sponsors what
it calls its partners they have a
problem it is not necessarily a new one
Bloomberg's Ehrenreich adela joins us
from Frankfurt he covers adidas FIFA's
closest and oldest partner Aaron what is
the mood inherit saga now rock right now
hey Brendan thanks so I'm based here in
Frankfurt not all that far from adi das
headquarters in bavaria yep adidas is
this company has as you know this really
long history that's tied up with world
cup soccer which is the premier product
of FIFA they go back decades with the
world cup it's tied into their identity
they have a CEO Herbert Heiner who's to
be an amateur soccer player who's
involved in professional soccer they tie
their whole identity with performance in
soccer shoes they need this exposure at
the same time you know for years there
have been of course these allegations
swirling around FIFA you've seen the
sponsors led by adidas and others kind
of look the other way on things and now
you're seeing some tougher rhetoric the
candidates tough quandary for these
companies they can't afford to have
their brand tainted by this but at the
same time there's a lot at stake Aaron
you've done a survey of what the visa
was using what FIFA's partners have said
where's the toughest rhetoric coming
from among those seven partners well
we've seen we've seen visa as you said
come out pretty strongly overnight visa
the credit card company has been a long
time top sponsor of the FIFA World Cup
and they said they expressed profound
disappointment and with what's happening
but I think almost to accompany you know
as you run down the list which is in my
story visa Adi das coke and some others
like McDonald's and bud they're all
talking about needs to be ride the high
ethical standards you know although
Giudice needs to shape up there at them
I would say there's one company there
that's missing which is Gazprom which
seems not concerned at all why might
that be
we got that statement from Gazprom as
well you know there's I've asked some of
the experts I've went back and gone to
some of the sports marketing experts who
I interviewed for this story and did
some checks with them again this morning
you know there's a very long history of
course of these sponsors not seeing much
or coming out with some pretty tepid
statements you have to remember how much
is at stake here